- The dollar is getting stronger
as it's starting to look like the US
has the strongest economy in the world,
but that's probably bad news
for US companies and the stock market.
I'm going to explain
what's happening in markets
that's pushing the value
of the dollar higher,
why it's happening now and
is expected to continue,
and why a stronger dollar
typically means tough times
for US stocks.
Let's get into it.
After rising to a 20-year
high in September 2022,
the dollar started falling
and largely kept falling
until July of this year.
The currency weakened pretty consistently,
declining along with inflation
as the stock market rose,
especially tech stocks.
But all that changed in July,
as US government bond
yields started to rise,
and stock prices started to fall.
Higher government bond yields
make currencies more attractive to traders
because they need a
country's local currency
to buy its government bonds.
When traders think a country's bond yields
are going to keep rising,
they typically buy up its currency,
and that pushes up the value.
This is an especially lucrative strategy
for traders who buy when
a currency's value is low,
and it appreciates.
Not only are they rewarded
by the high bond yields
but the currency's higher value
gives them an additional return.
Currencies also tend to rise in value
when a country's economy strengthens
in comparison to other countries.
That's what's happened to the US
over the past couple months.
July was when China's economy
first started showing signs of stress.
Weak retail sales, a big slowdown
in its real estate market,
and rising unemployment have
all slowed down Chinese growth.
That has had a negative
impact on many Asian
and European countries
because China's appetite
for their goods was helping
fuel their economies.
As Chinese demand pulled back,
economic growth in countries
that used euros, pounds,
and dollars, other than
the US, started to weaken.
The US economy is mostly
supported by spending on services,
like doctors, lawyers, and Uber drivers.
So a slowdown in global trade
doesn't hurt quite as much
as it does in places
like Germany or Vietnam.
Win Thin, Global Head of Currency Strategy
at Brown Brothers Harriman,
recently said, "If we look
everywhere around the world,
the US is sort of like
the last man standing,
and the dollar is coming
strong this year."
With a stronger economy,
the central bank of the
US, the Federal Reserve,
is expected to hold rates higher
for longer than other central banks.
Unfortunately, this is
not typically a good thing
for the stock market.
When the dollar hit its highest
level since 2002 last year,
half of all S&P 500 companies
mentioned the strong dollar
in their earnings reports,
and most of them weren't celebrating.
The S&P had its worst year since 2008.
Certainly, that wasn't all
about the strong dollar,
but as lots of CEOs told us
on their earnings calls, it didn't help.
A strong dollar makes items more expensive
in other countries,
so American companies
often sell fewer goods
when the dollar's value rises.
They also make less money
because when they convert
their foreign sales
back to dollars, they
often wind up with less.
In Q2, Apple saw its revenue decline
for the third quarter in a row
and said that if it weren't
for the strong dollar,
its revenue would've gone up.
With the dollar strengthening again,
look for more and more
companies to talk about it
in the upcoming earnings season.
It could also lead
to more companies reporting lower earnings
in the third quarter,
and with the economy starting to slow down
and fears about a recession rising,
that could really dent the stock market.
(bright music fades)